incisos un investigador estima que en un
determinado organismo el metabolismo
completo de la glucosa produce 30
moléculas de atp por cada molécula de
glucosa la energía liberada por la
completa oxidación de la glucosa en
condiciones estándar es de 686
kilocalorías por mol la energía liberada
por la hidrólisis de atp
ep y fosfato inorgánico en condiciones
estándar es de 7.3 kilocalorías por mol
calcular la cantidad de energía
disponible a partir de la hidrólisis de
30 moles de atp calcula la eficiencia de
la producción total de atp a partir de
un molde glucosa en el organismo
describe lo que sucede con el exceso de
energía que se libera del metabolismo de
la glucosa
muy bien voy a responder esta pregunta
por acá abajo vamos a responder la
primera parte vamos a calcular la
cantidad de energía disponible de la
hidrólisis de 30 moles de atp así que
déjame escribir esto
hidrólisis
30 moles
de atp
este es nuestro título así que tenemos
30 moles de atp
y nos dice en cuánta energía se libera
cuando se hidroliza el atp por mol dice
que la energía liberada por la
hidrólisis de atp
ep y fosfato inorgánico en condiciones
estándar es de 7.3 kilocalorías por mol
tenemos 30 moles que están siendo
hidrolizados así que 30 moles por 7.3
kilocalorías kilocalorías por mol y esto
va a ser igual a los moles se cancelan
con los moles las unidades van a ser
kilocalorías lo cual tiene lógica porque
queremos unidades de energía cuánto es
30 por 7.3 veamos 3 por 7.3 sería igual
a 21.9 por lo que esto va a ser igual a
219 dado que estamos multiplicando 7.3
por 30 219 kilocalorías
muy bien ahora vamos a hacer la segunda
parte
voy a hacer esto en un color diferente
si estuviera haciendo el examen no
podría usar varios colores pero esto es
para ayudarte a entender mejor lo que
está pasando calcula la eficiencia de la
producción total de atp a partir de un
molde glucosa en el organismo así que
voy a responder esto por aquí
la eficiencia
es igual
y la energía almacenada
en forma de atp
/
y la energía
total
de la oxidación
de la glucosa
y nos piden calcular la eficiencia de la
producción total de atp a partir de un
molde glucosa en el organismo así que
esto va a ser igual a
nos dicen que la producción de energía
cuando se oxida un molde glucosa dicen
que es de 686 kilocalorías por mol así
que en el denominador ponemos 686
kilocalorías
y en el numerador ponemos la energía
almacenada en el atp para este organismo
en particular que es capaz de producir
30 atp es el metabolismo completo de la
glucosa produce 30 moléculas de atp así
que por cada mol de glucosa está
produciendo 30 moles de atp y por lo que
ya calculamos eso es 219 kilocalorías
219 kilocalorías
así que ahora sólo tenemos que hacer
esta división permítanme hacerla aquí
219 dividido en 3 686 esto nos va a dar
un valor menor que cero vamos a hacerlo
de esta manera cuantas veces cada vez
686 en 2.190 bueno esto es un poco menos
de 700 y 7 por 3 es 21 por lo que vamos
a poner aquí un 3 y luego 3 por 6 es 18
3 por 8 es 24 más uno es 25
3 por 6 18 2 es 20 ahora voy a restar lo
veamos 90 menos 58 es 32 así que tengo
132 y bajo este cero
parece que esto podría ser una o dos
veces 686 vamos a ver dos por 686 sería
cercano a 1200 así que va a ser por uno
o tal vez redondear hemos por lo que uno
por 686 es 686
no restamos
y voy a reagrupar esto un poco así que
vamos a hacer de este un 10
esto 11 10 664 ahora puedo hacer esto un
2 y este un 11 11 menos 8 estrés y luego
12 menos 6 6 por lo que 686 llave en
6.340 sin duda va a ser más de 5 veces
así que si queremos redondear hacia
arriba esto va a ser un número mayor que
5 por lo que va a ser aproximadamente 32
% 32 por ciento de eficiencia
aproximadamente 32 por ciento de la
energía que puede ser producida por la
oxidación de la glucosa en realidad
termina siendo almacenada en el atp
ahora nos dicen describen lo que sucede
con el exceso de energía que se libera
del metabolismo de la glucosa qué pasa
con el otro 68% de la energía
y lo voy a hacer aquí el resto de la
energía se libera en forma de calor
el resto de la energía es liberada
en forma
de calor
y se podría decir que también es
liberada en forma de entropía aumentando
el número posible de estados de las
células hay más cosas que están
rebotando alrededor de diferentes
maneras pero esta es la forma más fácil
de pensar en ello que se libera en forma
de calor
en general cuando se piensa en cualquier
proceso termodinámica si se piensa en la
eficiencia se piensa en bueno donde está
toda esa energía perdida que no fue
capturada por lo general va a ser
liberado en forma de calor muy bien
ahora vamos a hacer el inciso de inciso
de las enzimas del ciclo de krebs
trabajan en el cito sol de las bacterias
pero entre las eucariotas las enzimas
trabajan principalmente en la
mitocondria muy bien sobre todo en la
mitocondria que es un orgánulo
plantea una pregunta científica que
conecte la localización subcelular de
las enzimas en el ciclo de krebs con la
evolución de las eucariotas de acuerdo
hemos hablado de esto antes cuando
hablamos por primera vez de las
mitocondrias en khan academy pero en
realidad si existe una teoría que dice
que las mitocondrias o los antepasados
de las mitocondrias podrían haber sido
organismos procariotas independientes
así que nuestra pregunta científica
podría ser
los antepasados
las mitocondrias
alguna vez
fueron organismos
procariotas
independientes
cuyos descendientes
fueron incorporados
dentro de los organismos
eucariotas
así que esta es una pregunta científica
y una muy interesante si observamos una
célula del cuerpo humano vamos a ver
estas mitocondrias en la gran mayoría de
las células y nos preguntamos si sus
antepasados alguna vez fueron organismos
independientes cuyos descendientes ahora
viven en simbiosis con nuestras células
porque son muy buenos en el ciclo de
krebs